[Music]
Oh.
Peace TV, the solution for humanity.
[Music]
Oh.
We begin today's program with a
recitation from the glorious Quran.
Many
[Music]
come.
for
[Music]
the translation from Surah Nissa chapter
4 verse 59. 9 I seek refuge with Allah
from Satan the accursed
in the name of Allah most gracious most
merciful.
Oh you who believe obey Allah and obey
the messenger and those charged with
authority among you.
If you differ in anything among
yourselves,
refer it to Allah and his messenger. If
you do believe in Allah and the last
day, that is best and most suitable for
final determination.
I now request brother Ashraf to give the
introduction of brother Zakayak and
we'll go ahead with brother Zakai's
speech. Thank you very much brothers and
sisters.
Jazakah brother Sayyad Zakir Dr. Zakir
Nyak is a medical doctor by professional
training but he's internationally
acclaimed as a narrator on Islam and
comparative religion. Dr. Zakir
clarifies and clears misconceptions
about Islam using Quran, authentic
Hadith and other religious scriptures
which he quotes verbitim in conjunction
with reason, logic and scientific facts.
He's popular for his critical analysis
and convincing answers to challenging
questions posed by audiences after his
public talks. He has delivered public
talks in the USA, Canada, UK, Saudi
Arabia, UAE, Australia, South Africa,
Botswana, Malaysia, Singapore, Hong
Kong, Thailand, Guyana, South America
and many other countries in addition to
numerous talks in India. No wonder
Sheikh Ahmed Dat the world famous aator
on Islam and comparative religion has
given Dr. Zakir the title Didat plus.
Dr. Zakir Nyak appears regularly on many
international TV channels in more than
150 countries of the world. More than
100 of his talks, dialogues, debates and
symposia are available on DVDs. He has
authored several books on Islam and
comparative religion.
Dear brothers and sisters, before I
invite Dr. Zakin to speak to you on the
topic Sharia barbaric or perfect, I
would request him to gift a copy of the
Quran and its Tamil translation to
brother Dr. Shipman
[Applause]
Dr. Zak nag brothers and sisters on the
topic Sharia barbaric or perfect.
Alhamdulillah.
the respected people on the dash, my
respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters. I welcome all of you with
the Islamic greetings. Assalamu alaykum.
May peace, mercy and blessings of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala of Almighty God be
on all of you.
The topic of
this evening's talk is
Sharia.
Barbaric or perfect.
Sharia is the complete code of Islamic
law which pertains to the rights and
duties of the Muslim. It regulates
the lives of the people.
It is comprehensive
and includes
from the minute detail about eating,
drinking, clothing up to the complex
system of law making. The word Sharia it
literally means the clear path to
follow. The Islamic Sharia
it is derived from four sources. The
first source is the glorious Quran.
The Quran is the last and final
revelation of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
of almighty God which was revealed to
the last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. The Quran is
the word of God of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala and it is also called as the
furan the criteria to judge right from
wrong. The Quran was revealed by Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala by almighty God to
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
through Archangel Gabriel
1400 years ago
and it was approximately 23 years.
The Quran
contains 114 suras
or chapters
and contains more than 6,000 ayats,
signs or verses.
The glorious Quran was revealed in
Arabic.
But many scholars have translated this
glorious Quran, the word of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala into almost all the
major languages of the world.
This Quran, the word of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala is the highest and the first
source of the Sharia.
The second source is the sunnah.
Sunnah means the way of the prophet or
the doings
of the prophet according to the say
hadith the authentic sayings of the
prophet. The sunnah or the authentic
hadith are supplementary to the Quran.
They act as a commentary to the Quran.
It gives an explanation
to the verses of the Quran.
And in the sunnah
the commandments
of the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
comes on the top.
Then comes his actions
and many a time for the details
of his commandments
you may have to look into the life
of the sahabas. Allah says in the Quran
in several places including surah nah
chapter number 4:59 Allah says
obey Allah and obey the messenger obey
the messenger means obey the sunnah the
authentic sayings of the prophet and the
prophet said
that first look in the Quran
then look in my example
and his sayings and then
if you want more details is look into
the this generation then the next
generation then the next generation. If
you want to find more details about the
life of the prophet how he led the best
people who understood
the sayings of the prophet were the
companions were the sahabas those who
live with the prophet those who saw the
prophet and who died in the state of
iman. So if you want to understand the
hadith much better
if there difference opinion you have to
look in the lifestyles of the sales the
three generations. If you want to find
more details and more explanation
you can go into the lifestyle of the
Sahabas then the next generation then
the next generation that's it.
So the sunnah of the prophet the
authentic a hadith is the second source
of the Sharia. The third source is thema
that is the consensus of opinions
or the agreement
of the opinions of the sahabas of the
companions of the prophet followed by
the consensus of the opinions of safet
and the consensus of opinions of the
Muslim jurist of the first three century
of hijra.
If you cannot find the answer in the
Quran or cannot find any opinion in the
Quran then look in the sunnah of the
prophet in the authentic hadith. If you
don't find it there then you go to the
third source that is the
consensus of opinion. This is the third
source. And the fourth source is chaos.
Chaos means to judge and come closer
to make a judgment based on a reasoning
that if you don't find any direct
indication in the Quran or in the sunnah
of the prophet or in the
you can use your own logic to try and
find out the answer based on the other
verses of the Quran or the hadith of the
prophet or the
using analogy.
If direct there is no indication about a
particular thing
then you should look into the other
verses of the Quran and the Sunnah and
the try and find a relevant answer by
using analogy. But this can only be used
after the it can be used in Islamic
state where proper Islamic Sharia is
followed. Basically there are four
sources for the Sharia. Number one and
the highest in authority is the glorious
Quran, the word of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. Number two is the sunnah of the
prophet, the authentic hadith. Number
three is the number four is the kios.
The Islamic Sharia is a complete code of
conduct.
It gives a person a complete way of
life, how a life should be led. But
unfortunately
we find in the media and many critics of
Islam
they present the Sharia as barbaric
and
most of their allegations regarding the
Sharia most of them major of them they
revolve around two aspects.
One is the punishment in Islam.
They may show a poster or the front
cover of a book of a man being whipped.
Maybe the naked back is being whipped.
And the second aspect is women in Islam
that they are subjugated. They may show
a woman in hijab.
These two are the main factors which the
critics of Islam they attack the Sharia
and they say it is barbaric. And there
are a few others.
Time will not permit us to discuss all
the aspects of the Sharia. Neither will
time permit us to reply to all the
allegations and the criticism of the
media and the critics of Islam in the
limited time available. Inshallah I will
try and clarify a few of the
misconception of the Sharia. The first
as I mentioned most of the western
writers and the Islam they attack Islam
because of the way of punishment.
In Islamic law in Islamic Sharia the
punishment is barbaric.
Islam is a complete way of life and
compared to the other ways of life most
of the other religions if you analyze
they speak good things. most of the
religions including Islam. But the
difference between Islam and the other
religion is that Islam besides speaking
good things, it shows you a way how to
achieve that state of goodness.
For example, all the major religion of
the world, they tell us that we should
not rob. Hinduism says you should not
rob. Christianity says you should not
rob. Islam says you should not rob. So
what's the difference between Islam and
the other ways of life? between Islam
and the other religions. The difference
is that Islam besides telling us the
good things, it shows us a way how to
achieve that state of goodness.
In the Islamic Sharia,
we have the third pillar of Islam as
zakal.
That is every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level,
more than 85 g of gold, he or she should
give 2.5%
of that saving every lunar year in
charity.
If every rich human being gives charity,
poverty will be eradicated from this
world. There will not be a single human
being who will die of hunger.
And Allah says in the Quran in surah al-
Hashar chapter 59 verse number 7 it says
that zakat has been prescribed so that
it prevents the wealth from circulating
only amongst the rich.
So obligated charity is a part of the
Islamic Sharia. It's further all those
who are rich who has a saving of more
than 85 grams of gold should give 2.5%
of that saving every lunar year in
charity.
And after that if suppose someone robs
Allah says in the Quran in surah Maida
chapter number 5 verse number 38 as to
the thief beat a man or a woman chop of
his or her hand as a punishment from
Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
Many people will say chopping off the
hands in this age of science and
technology Islam is a barbaric religion.
It is ruthless faith.
And many people think that if they go to
Saudi Arabia where this law is
practiced, every second person they come
across,
they will see that the hands have been
chopped. Many people think that if they
go to Saudi Arabia where this law is
practiced, every second person's hand
will be chopped off. Believe me, I have
been to Saudi Arabia several times,
empty number of times. I have not come
across a single human being whose hands
have been chopped off. There may be a
few whose hands have been chopped but I
have not come across a single.
The law is so strict that a person will
think 10 times before committing the
crime. The Islamic Sharia is such it
gives you advice that don't rob.
But every human being will not follow
this advice.
Those who have faith in Allah may
follow. Everyone will not. So what
solution do you have for that? The next
solution is if they don't follow the
commandment of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
there has to be a punishment
and today America is supposed to be one
of the most advanced countries in the
world. Do you know it has one of the
highest rates of theft and robbery in
the world.
I am asking a simple question that if
you implement the Islamic Sharia in
America in USA that every rich person
who has a saving of more than 85 grams
of gold should give 2.5% of that saving
in charity every lunar year and after
that if anyone robs chop of his or her
hand as a punishment I am asking a
question will the rate of theft and
robbery in America will it increase will
it remain the same or will it decrease?
it will decrease. It's a practical law.
You implement the Sharia and you get
results. Therefore, I say that the
Islamic Sharia is perfect. We introduce
laws for results not just to be
mentioned in the books
and people may argue they think that if
you implement then you know how many
people are robbing oh there are
thousands of people robbing in America.
So do you mean you'll have to chop off
thousands of people's hand? The moment
you implement the law within a couple of
people all the rest God willing we stop
robbing because now they know that if we
arrested we can get through we can bribe
we won't get a severe punishment but the
moment the punishment is severe
a person will think 10 times before
robbing and immediately the rate will
come down and
people fail to realize that Islamic
Sharia is complete it's Perfect.
That doesn't mean that if a poor man
robs bread because he's hungry, his
hands will be chopped off. If a poor man
robs because he's hungry, it's the duty
of the state, the Islamic state to
provide food to him.
Why did he had to rob for food?
It is the duty of the ummah. It is the
duty of the people to see to it that the
neighbors don't go hungry. But natural
this punishment has it rules and
regulations that only if you rob a
particular big amount etc then it is
implemented and the question of a person
robbing food should not arise in Islamic
state
that's the reason the least state of
robbery in any part of the world it's in
Saudi Arabia
it's a practical law you implement it
and you get results
this was just an example of the
punishment and the logic behind this
punishment.
So people who worry that hands will be
chopped off the moment you implement the
Sharia the punishment need not be
implemented it may be implemented once
in a blue moon. The other point which
many skeptics they talk about Islam
mainly is about the women's rights in
Islam.
I will not permit to talk about all the
allegations
but in short
these critics they say that the women in
Islam they are subjugated
they don't have their rights they aren't
equal
in Islam men and women are equal but
equality does not mean identicality
they're equal but they are not identical
subhanah wa ta'ala our creator has made
the men and women biologically
different, physiologically different,
psychologically different. So depending
upon the psychological makeup, the
biological makeup, the physiological
makeup, Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has
given different roles for the men and
women
on many aspects. If you analyze,
men and women, they're equal. In some
aspects the women have a degree of
advantage. In some aspect the men have a
degree of advantage but overall they're
equal.
Let me give you an example that if in an
examination two students student A and
student B both get 80 out of 100. Both
come out first.
If you analyze the answer sheet the 10
answers to 10 questions each kind 10
marks. In answer to question number one,
student A gets 9 out of 10 and student B
gets 7 out of 10. So in answer to
question number one, student A has a
degree of advantage over B. In answer to
question number two, student B gets 9
out of 10 and student A gets 10 out of
10. So in answer to question number two,
student B has a degree of advantage over
student A. In all the remaining eight
answers both get eight out of 10. So if
you add up both get 80 out of 100.
Overall they equal
but answer to question number one
student a degree of advantage. In answer
to question number two student B are the
degree of advantage. Similarly men and
women in Islam overall they're equal. In
some aspects the women have a degree of
advantage. In some aspects the men have
a degree of advantage. For example, it's
mentioned in Sai Bkhari volume number
eight in the book of Ada chapter number
two had number two. Once a person
approached the prophet and asked him
that who deserves the maximum love and
companionship in this world? The prophet
said your mother. The man asked after
that who? The prophet repeated your
mother. The man asked after that who?
The prophet again repeated your mother.
The man asked after that who? Then the
prophet said your father. That means 75%
3/4 of the love and companionship of the
children
goes to the mother. 25% 1/4 goes to the
father. In short, the mother gets the
gold medal. She gets the silver medal as
well as the bronze medal. The father has
to be satisfied with the mere
consolation prize.
So in this aspect, if you analyze the
women have a degree of advantage. Why?
But natural because our mothers they
bore us in the womb for 9 months and a
prophet said even if you give them a
mountain of gold for what the trouble
they have taken for 9 months you cannot
compensate it. So because of that when
it comes to companionship
of the children the mother has a degree
of advantage.
Let me give you another example. Suppose
a robber if he enters the house I'll not
say I believe in Muhammad liberalization
I'll not tell my wife to go and fight
the robber
but natural as Allah says in the Quran
in surah Nisa chapter number four verse
number 34 that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
has given more strength to the men
so but naturally since Allah has given
the degree of advantage in physical
strength it is our duty to support and
protect the women. So here in strength
we have a degree of advantage. In many
other aspects
men and women are same. So in short this
was just a short reply to the
allegations
of the critics of Islam that Islamic
Sharia is barbaric as compared to the
women's rights in Islam. And for more
details you can refer to my video
cassette women's rights in Islam
modernizing or outdated.
As I mentioned earlier that most of the
religions basically they speak good
things but Islam besides speaking good
things it shows you a way how to achieve
a state of goodness
and
people object and they have different
opinion
how should the law be and one of the
common objection is that women they are
subjugated because of the Islamic hijab
and they say that the Islamic hijab it's
not modest at all it's not for modesty
it is for subjugating the woman.
And if you analyze and if you look
around us today in the world, the level
of modesty, it keeps on differing from
individual to individual depending upon
the surrounding and the society.
For example, in certain Muslim Arab
countries, even looking at a woman, even
staring at a woman is considered
immodest.
Here in India,
you can look at a woman, you can talk to
a woman. But if you touch a woman, it's
immodest. Therefore, the Indian sort of
greeting is with the folded hands.
As long as you don't touch a woman in
India, it is considered modest.
If you go to certain western countries,
shaking hands, men and women, men and
ladies, it's modest.
You can shake hands, you can talk, you
can stay, no problem. In fact, if a lady
puts a hand forward or if a gen puts a
hand forward and the opposite sex does
not shake hands, it's considered that
they are uneducated
or that they uncultured.
So there shaking hands is within the
modesty level. In some western
countries, you can even kiss a woman.
You can kiss a lady, a man can kiss a
lady on the cheek, on the lips, no
problem. It is modest. In certain
western countries, you can do what you
want. The men and women can do what they
want as long as they do with permission
of each other. It is considered modest.
So the level of modesty keeps on
changing. Now how will we human being
decide which is the best? Which is
modest. For example, if you go to USA or
go to the western countries, there a
young lady if she wears a mini skirt or
short she's considered modest.
But here that same lady comes or any
lady in India or in Madras wears a mini
skirt or short, she'll be considered
immodest.
Right or wrong?
Yes or no?
I was there in America a few years back.
There's the American who told me that
Indian woman, the Indian women, they're
immodest. I was shocked that how come
the Indian women immodest? He told me
that the Indian women they wear the sari
and they expose their belly.
So for the American exposing the belly
is immodest. And then I thought what
he's saying it makes sense for him
modesty level is that you should cover
your belly. Now we eastern people we
Indians we think we're very modest but
for the westerner exposing the belly is
immodest.
So who's to decide what is modest or
what is immodest?
The best one to decide is our creator is
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is almighty
god.
So let's analyze what is mentioned
in the Islamic Sharia the Quran and the
hadith about the modesty level and
people who lay an allegation
that Islam subjugates the woman because
of hijab. I would like to tell them that
if you go back in history at the time of
Babylonian,
the Babylonian civilization, they
illreated the woman, if a man committed
murder, instead of he getting the
punishment, his wife was put to death.
In the Greek civilization,
they had a concept of an imaginary woman
by the name of Pandora who was the cause
of all the misfortunes.
Though initially they believed in
chastity, but because of ego and fame,
prostitution became common. In the Roman
civilization, nudity was very common.
Prostitution and promiscuity was very
common.
In the Egyptian civilization, the woman
was considered as a sign of the devil.
And in the Arab civilization, before the
Quran was revealed, very often when a
female was born, she was put to death.
She was buried alive. Islam is the first
religion and prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is the major benefactor
who uplifted the woman. After Islam gave
rights to the woman,
it also showed them a way how to
maintain their modesty, how to maintain
their rights, how to maintain the
position. That's the reason hijab has
been prescribed.
People normally talk about hijab of the
women but Allah subhanana wa ta'ala God
almighty in the Quran he first speaks
about the hijab for the men and then for
the women. Allah says in the Quran in
surah nur chapter number 24 verse number
30 say to the believing man that he
should lower his gaze and guard his
modesty. Whenever a man looks at a woman
any brazen thought comes in his mind he
should lower his gaze. Any unashamed
thought comes in his mind he should
lower his gaze.
One day there was a Muslim who was
staring at a girl for a long time. I
told him, "Brother, what are you doing?
It's not allowed in Islam." So he told
me that a beloved prophet said, "The
first glance is permitted. The second is
prohibited. I have not completed half my
glance."
What did the prophet mean when he said
the first glance is forgiven, the second
is prohibited. That does not mean a
person can look at a woman for 10
minutes without blinking and saying, "I
have not complete my glance."
It means that if you unintentionally
look at a woman, do not intentionally
look at her again to feast on a beauty.
The next verse speaks about the hijab
for the woman. Allah says in the Quran
in surah nur chapter number 24 verse
number 31 say to the believing woman
that she should lower her gaze and guard
her modesty and display not a beauty
except what appears ordinary of and draw
a head covering over a bosom and display
not a beauty except in front of her
husband her sons her father and a big
list of maram the close relatives who
she can't marry is given there are
basically six criteria
for the hijab which is mentioned in the
Quran and the authentic hadith the first
is
the extent. For the man, it's from the
navl to the knee. For the woman, the
complete body should be covered. The
only part that can be seen are the face
and the hands up to the wrist. There are
many scholars who say that they should
be covered. The remaining five criteria
are the same for the man and the woman.
The second criteria, the clothes they
wear, it should be loose. It should not
reveal the figure. Third, it should not
be transparent so that you could see
through. Fourth, it should not be so
glamorous so that it attacks the
opposite sex. Fifth, it should not
resemble that of the opposite sex. And
sixth, it should not resemble and be a
sign of the unbeliever.
These are basically the six criteria of
hijab. And Allah says in the Quran in
surah Azab chapter number 33 verse
number 59 that oh prophet
tell your wives and your daughters and
the believing woman that when they go
abroad they should put on the cloak so
that they shall be recognized and it
will prevent them from being molested.
Quran says hijab has been prescribed for
the women so that it will prevent them
from being molested.
Suppose
there are two twin sisters who are very
beautiful wife very beautiful and if
they're walking down the streets of
Madras and if one twin sister she's
wearing the Islamic clothes complete
body covered except the face and the
hands up to the wrist and the other twin
sister she's wearing the western clothes
the mini skirts or shorts and if round
the corner there is a hooligan there's a
ruffian who's waiting for a catch who's
waiting to tease a girl I'm asking a
question which girl will it tease will
it tease the girl wearing the Islamic
hijab or will will tease the girl
wearing the western clothes, the mini
skirts are short.
Which girl will he tease?
But natural he will tease the girl
wearing the miniskirts or short. So
Quran rightly says that hijab has been
prescribed for the woman so that it will
prevent them from being molested
and after that
if any man rapes any woman the Islamic
Sharia says he gets capital punishment.
People will say capital punishment in
this age of science and technology.
Islam is a barbaric religion. It's a
merciless religion. It's a ruthless way
of life. But when I ask this question
and I've asked this question to hundreds
of non-Muslims
that suppose God forbid someone rapes
your mother
and if you are made the judge and if the
rapist is brought in front of you, what
punishment will you give him? And
believe me 100%. All of the non-Muslims
said we will put him to death. So why
these double standards? When someone
rapes your mother, you want to put him
to death. When somebody rapes somebody
else's mother, you say that Islam is a
barbaric religion.
When someone rapes your mother, you want
to put him to death. When someone rapes
somebody else's mother, you say the
death penalty is a barbaric way of life.
Why the double standards? The only
person who differed when I asked this
question was a smart Alex in America.
But during question answer session I
keep on traveling. He told me brother
Zakir
if someone rapes my mother I will not
put him to death I will give him five
years imprisonment rigorous
imprisonment.
Said fine. I said do you know according
to the American statistics
those people that are convicted for rape
after they go out more than 95% of them
they again commit rape. So if you want
your mother to be raped again you're
most welcome. We Muslims don't want our
mothers to be raped. He told if that's
the case then I'll put him to death at
the first time.
And if you analyze America which happens
to be one of the most advanced countries
in the world. Do you know that according
to the statistics of FBI in the year
1990 alone there were 1 lak 2555
cases of rapes reported. 102,555
cases of rapes were reported and the FBI
report said that only 16% of the rape
cases were reported. So if you want to
know exactly how many rapes took place,
you have to multiply by 6.25 and you get
a total of 640,968
rapes that took place in 1990 in USA
alone. If you divide this figure by 365,
the number of days, you get an average
of 1,756
rapes that took place in America
according to FBI in the year 1990.
Every day, 1,756.
If you read another report
of the National Crime Victimization
Survey Bureau, the US Department of
Justice,
it says in the year 1996,
every day on average 2,713
cases of rapes took place. 2,713.
That means every 32 second one rape took
place in America in 1996.
We are here in this auditorium for the
past one and a half hour
already
more than 100 rift may have taken place
in America since the time we are here.
I am asking a question that if you
implement the Islamic share in America
that is any man when he looks at a woman
and any brazen thought comes in his mind
he should lower his gaze and after that
the woman there should be the Islamic
hijab complete body covered except the
face and the hands up to the wrist and
after that if any man rapes a woman he
gets death penalty he gets capital
punishment I am asking the question that
will the rate of rape in America will it
increase will it remain the same or will
it decrease
it will decrease. It's a practical law.
You implement the shar and you get
results.
That's why I say that Islam besides
talking good things. All the religions
say that you should not molest, you
should not rape. But Islam shows you a
way how to have a society in which
people will not rape and molest.
And the least rate of rape in any
country in the world, it's in Saudi
Arabia where this law is practiced.
Therefore, I say that the Islamic Sharia
is a perfect law. It is the most
practical law. It shows you a way how to
achieve peace.
It may sound barbaric to those people
who may not know the figures and the
background of what's happening in the
world. A law is a code in which you can
get results,
where you can get peace.
There are many critics who say the
Islamic Sharia it's barbaric. It allows
a man to have more than one wife. In
fact, if you read the Quran, Quran is
the only religious scripture on the face
of the earth which says marry only one.
There is no other religious scripture on
the face of the earth besides the Quran
which says marry only one. You read the
Bible, you read Bhagat Gita, you read
Mahabharat, you read the Rama and you
read the Vedas. There's no religious
scripture on the face of death except
the Quran which says marry only one.
If you read the Hindu scriptures, if you
read Ramayan, the father of Sri Ram, his
name was Kingdash, he had more than one
wife. If you read the Vishnu Sutra, it
mentions in chapter number 24 verse
number one that a Brahman can have four
wives.
And if you read Mahabharat
Krishna, he had how many wives? 4 10,000
10,000 he had 16,18 wives.
So when S Krishna can have 16,198 wives
so why can't we have four?
Further if you read the Jewish
scriptures if you read the Old Testament
Solomon had 700 wives according to the
Bible according to the Old Testament
Abraham had three wives. In the Jewish
religion you can have as many as you
wish. It is later on in the 10th and the
11th century when Rabbi Gers Benhuda he
passed a sod that the Jews should marry
only one. Even till as late as 1950 the
Jewish community living in the Muslim
country sephratic people they married
more than one wife. Even in the
Christian religious book the Bible
nowhere does it say marry only one. You
can marry as many as you wish. It is
later on the church which put a
restriction that the Christian should
marry only one. Even in India, the Hindu
scriptures do not tell that you should
marry only one. It is the Indian law,
the Indian penal code which passed a law
in 1954, a Hindu marriage special act.
A Hindu marriage special act. We said
that a Hindu should marry only one. The
Hindu scriptures give you permission.
You can marry as many as you wish. The
Christian and the Jewish scriptures say
you can marry as many as you wish. 4,
10, 100, 5,000, 10,000, all of it.
And if you read the report of the
committee of the status of women in
Islam published in 1975 on page number
66 and 67 it says that in a span of 10
years
between 1951 and 1961 the Muslims in
India 4.31%
they did polygamous marriages mean they
married more than one and amongst the
Hindu the percentage was 5.06 06.
So according to statistics, the Hindu do
more polygamous marriages than the
Muslims.
Let's analyze what does the Quran say.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Nisa
chapter number four verse number three
that marry women of a choice in twos,
threes or fours. But if you can't do
justice, marry only one. This statement
marry only one is only given in the
Quran and no other religious scripture.
You can marry more than one up to four
only if you can do justice. If you can't
do justice, marry only one.
And Allah says in the Quran in surah Isa
chapter number 4 verse number 129 that
it is difficult to be just between your
wives. So don't turn away from them
altogether.
Many people think that marrying four
wives is compulsory.
And I have my friends in Bombay
in the medical college. One of my friend
told me you Muslims more than 80% marry
four wives. So I told where you get this
from I know. So I told him I challenge
you. Get me 10 people in India who have
got four wives and I will give 100,000
rupees. 10 people. In my full life I
have not come across a single Muslim
Indian who has got four wives. I know
there are many people outside India in
the Arab countries which have got four
wives. But there's a misconception
amongst the Indian non-Muslims that
every Muslim marries four wives.
In fact, marrying more than one wife is
not further in Islam. It's not
compulsory. It is more by it's optional.
If you want to marry, no problem. But if
you marry, you should be just between
your wives. Let us analyze what is the
logical reason why Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala has permitted a man to have up to
four wives. By nature male and female
they're born in equal proportion.
But in the pediatric age itself
you ask any pediatrician he will tell
you that the female child can fight the
germs and diseases much better than the
male child. So in the pediatric age
itself there are more male children
dying as compared to female children. So
in pediatic age itself there are more
females as compared to males. As life
goes on, there's death due to cigarette
smoking, alcoholism, due to accidents,
due to war. There are more male dying as
compared to females.
Today, if you analyze in the world,
there are more females in the world as
compared to males.
Except in a few third world countries
like India. And the reason that in India
there are more males as compared to
females because of female infanticide.
According to a statistics which came on
the BBC on the program assignment let
her die there was a British reporter by
the name of Emily Becker she says that
every day
in India more than 3,000 fetuses are
being aborted after they identified that
they're females. That means more than 1
million female fetuses are being aborted
every year in India after they
identified that they're females.
And according to the Tamil Nadu
government hospital report
it says that out of 10 females born
alive four are put to death. If you stop
this evil practice of female infanticide
and female feticide then even in India
the female population will be more than
the male population. Today if you
analyze in New York alone there are 1
million females more than males. In USA
alone there are 7.8 million females more
than males. In UK alone, there are 4
million females and more than males. In
Germany alone, there are 5 million
females and more than males. In Russia
alone, there are 9 million females and
more than males. And Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala, God Almighty alone knows how
many millions of females are more than
males throughout the world. If I agree
who says that one man should only marry
one woman
and suppose my sister or suppose his
sister happens to live in America and if
the market is saturated and every man
has found a woman for himself yet there
will be 7.8 million females in USA who
will not find life partners.
The only option remaining for them is
that they either marry a man who already
has a wife or become public property.
People say public property zakir you're
using such a harsh word it is the most
sophisticated word I can use I cannot
use a better word and any modest woman
should prefer being a wife of a man who
already has a wife than becoming public
property and if you analyze in the
western countries having mistress is
very common 2 10 20 30 40 no problem as
many as you want you can have
the American studies say on average a
person has eight different sexual
partners before he marries an American
on average. Some may have two, some may
have five, some have 20, some have 30.
Having eight on average eight sexual
partners before you marry, it goes down
the throat.
But having more than one wife, it
doesn't go down the throat. If you
compare that when a woman is a mistress,
she's dishonored. She doesn't get her
rights.
In fact, if a woman even if she becomes
a second wife, alhamdulillah, she gets a
right, she gets the honor and she's
protected.
So if you analyze the reason that Islam
has given permission that some men can
have more than one wife is to protect
the modesty of the woman, it not to
degrade her.
Further, if you analyze that in Islam,
the woman is considered as a mahasana,
as a fortress against the devil.
Unlike in other religion which is
considered as a sign of the devil and a
beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said it's mentioned say
bkari volume number seven in the book of
nikah chapter number three had number
four that oh young people whoever has
the means to get married should get
married
and the prophet said there is no monastm
in Islam the prophet also said that
whoever marries he completes half his
dean
once during question answer time
somebody asked me that does it mean that
if I'm married twice, I complete my full
dean.
What did the prophet meant when he said
marriage completes half your dean?
Marriage prevents you from fornication,
from adultery, from promiscuity, from
homosexuality, which are half the evil
in the society. Only if you marry do you
have an opportunity to be a father or
mother. Only if you marry do you have an
opportunity to be a husband or wife
which are very important duties in
Islam. So irrespective whether you marry
once or twice, you only complete half
your deen. And the prophet said, "Anyone
who does not marry, he's not of me."
And the Quran describes nikah
in surah nisa chapter number four verse
number 21 as a msq as a sacred covenant.
And for a nikah to somnize the
permission of both would be husband and
wife is important. The woman and the man
both is equally important. Our beloved
prophet said it's mentioned in Sai Bkari
volume number 7 in the book of nikah
chapter number 69 hadith number 49 that
once a lady by the name of khadim
alansary she approached the prophet and
she said that my father has forced me to
marry a man who I did not like and the
prophet he nullified the marriage so
permission of both would it be husband
and wife is equally important in Islam
and in Islam for a marriage to Alumni is
mah is compulsory. Allah says in surah
nisa chapter number four verse number
four that gift to the woman in marriage
a marital gift mah is compulsory. A da
is compulsory. The wouldbe husband
should give a da to the wouldbe wife. In
the Indian culture it is opposite. Dowi
in India
the bride gives to the bridegroom and
it's very much prevalent in India and
unfortunately it has even crept into the
Muslim society
and depending upon the status of the man
that person demands thawi if he's a
graduate he may demand one lakh if he's
an engineer he may demand five lakh if
he's a doctor he may demand 20 lakhs as
they are selling herds and cattle in the
marketplace in Islam
demanding dowi directly or indirectly is
prohibited. You cannot give indication
that my son he likes to travel in a
Mercedes car indicating I want a
Mercedes car for dowi. My son he likes
to live in a three-bedroom apartment.
Giving indication you want three-bedroom
apartment for dowi. Demanding dowi
directly or indirect in Islam is
prohibited. Willingly if the parents
of the girl give you something there's
no problem. But demanding directly or
indirectly is prohibited. In fact, it is
the wouldbe bridegroom who gives da mah
to the wouldbe bride. So this is how
alhamdulillah Islam protects the status
of the woman.
Allah says in the Quran in surah N
chapter number 24 verse number four that
if anyone
lays an allegation against the modesty
of a woman anyone says wrong things
about a woman against a modesty and if
he cannot support it with four witnesses
they get 80 lashes each.
That means if someone lays allegation
against woman abusing and in our society
it's very common you can abuse on the
mother and father and daughter your
sister and you can get away in Islamic
Sharia if you lay an allegation against
the modesty of a woman and cannot
produce four witnesses you get 80 lashes
and if you produce four witnesses and if
anyone falters in the cross- examination
all of them get 80 lashes you may say 80
lashes barbaric so abusing and laying an
allegation on the modest of women is not
barbaric.
So depending what is barbaric for you,
the rule of the Islamic Sharia, the law
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala protects
the modesty and uplifts the modesty of
women.
Unlike the western culture in the name
of western civilization, the western
society claiming to uplift the woman
have actually degraded her to a status
of concubine, mistresses and society
butterflies which are hidden behind the
colorful screen of art and culture.
The western society in the name of woman
liberalization
have actually degraded the woman. They
claim to uplift the woman
but if you analyze they have degraded
her in the name of art and culture they
are selling the daughters. They're
selling the mothers. And the example I
gave two days back of the ad of the BMW
which I was told is a very famous ad
that a lady
in a bikini stands in front of the BMW
car which is very famous among the
youngsters and the caption says test
drive her now who the girl or the car
what are they doing in the name of
advancement
civilization
they're selling their mothers they're
selling their daughters they're selling
their wives we in Islam
We protect our women. We love them. We
rever them and we honor them. We don't
want to sell them.
Furthermore,
there allegation that in Islam during
inheritance, why do the women get half?
Islam degrades the woman. In
inheritance, the women get half as
compared to the men. the daughter gets
half as compared to the son. So why this
injustice?
If you read the Quran, the Quran
mentioned about inheritance in several
places. In surah bakar chapter number 2
verse number 180. In surah bakar chapter
number 2 verse number 240 in surisa
chapter number 4 verse number 729. In
surahis chapter number 4 verse number 19
in sunis chapter number 4 verse number
33. In surah chapter number 4 verse
number 176 in surah maida chapter number
5 verse number 1058. There are many
verses which talk about inheritance. But
the verse which gives the details of the
portion is surah chapter number 4 verse
number 11 and 12 and verse number 176.
Allah says in the Quran in surah is
chapter number 4 verse number 11 that as
to the inheritance of a children the
male will get double than that of the
females.
If you have only daughters two or more
then they share in two3. If you have
only one daughter she gets half. And the
verse continues, your parents get one
sixth each if you have children.
If you have no children, your mother
gets one/3 if the deceased person has no
brother as well as sister after paying
of all your debts. The next verse of
surah Nisa chapter 4 verse number 12
says that in what your wives leave for
you, you get half if there are no
children, you get 1/4 if there are
children. in what you leave for your
wives. If there are no children, the
wives they share in 1/4
and if there are children, they share in
1/8. It's difficult to remember. You can
go home and check it up. Surah nisa
chapter 4 verse number 11 and 12. But on
the whole I do agree that most of the
times the female gets half the sh as
compared to the male. But there are
times when they get equal mother and
father if their children get equal. But
on the whole I do agree most of the time
they get half. What is the logic behind
this? The logic is that in Islam,
the woman is financially more secured as
compared to the man. In Islam,
it's the duty of the father and the
brother before a woman is married. And
it's the duty of the husband and the son
after she's married to look after her
lodging, boarding, clothing and all
financial aspects. So the financial
burden is laid on the shoulder of the
man not of the woman.
Now after Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has
laid the burden on the shoulder of the
man Allah has to be just. Allah says in
surah na ch 4:40 Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala he's never unjust in the least
degree. Suppose there is a person who
dies
and he leaves
two children one son one daughter and
after giving the shares of the wives and
the other relatives suppose 150,000
rupees is spending so according to
Islamic Sharia if a son and a daughter
is there and the balance is 150,000
after giving the other shares the son
gets 100,000 rupees and the daughter
will get 50,000 rupees now I'm asking a
question. Would you prefer
receiving 100,000 rupees and spending
maybe 90,000 on the family because the
man if he get 100,000 rupees he has to
spend on the family or would you prefer
receiving 50,000 and not spending a
single pin on yourself
because when the woman receives the
money she need not spend any of her
money even for her clothing lodging and
boarding even for her clothing lodging
boarding it's the duty of the man
But naturally anyone would prefer
receiving 50,000 rupees and keeping
everything for themselves than receiving
100,000 rupees and spending maybe 80 or
90% on the family. So Allah subhanana wa
tala sincerely laid the burden on the
man for financial aspects. That's the
reason he gives them double share. But
on the whole if you analyze the woman
are more benefiting in financial aspect
as compared to the men. So they are
financially more protected.
Further if you analyze one of the common
allegations I'm done with to deal with
many
is the concept of jihad and there's a
misconception not only amongst the
non-Muslims but even among the Muslims
that any war fought by any Muslim for
any reason whether it be for personal
gain whether it be for fame whether it
be for politics it is called as jihad
any war fought by any Muslim is not
called jihad jihad comes from the root
Arabic word jihad which means to strive
which means to struggle. It means in the
Islamic Sharia, in the Islamic context,
jihad means to strive against one's own
evil inclination. It also means to
strive to make the society better. It
even means to strive in the battlefield
in self-defense. It even means to strive
to fight against oppression and tyranny.
Jihad means to strive. It means to
struggle.
There's another misconception.
Many people translate the word jihad as
holy war. If you translate holy war into
Arabic, it is harbukadasa. And if you
read the Quran, nowhere in the Quran is
harbukadasa mentioned. Nowhere any
hadith is it mentioned makadasa. So
jihad
is not holy war.
This word holy war was first used by the
orientalist to describe the crusades
when the Christians when they conquered
many countries in the name of
Christianity and they killed thousands
of people that was called a holy war.
The Islamic jihad is not called holy
war. One of the types
of jihad is fighting it is ketal
but natural fighting in the way of Allah
subhana wa tala and I've given a
detailed talk on jihad when I'd come one
and a half year back in the same city of
Chennai you can refer to the video
cassette but if you analyze
these people they pick up vers of the
Quran and they say the Quran says that
wherever you find a kafir you kill them
indicating wherever you find non-Muslim
you kill it's a barbaric religion and
one of the most famous verses quoted is
of Surah Toba chapter number 9 verse
number five and these critics they say
including Arun Shuri he writes in his
book the world of fatwa he quotes surah
tba chapter 9 verse number 5 and says
that the Quran says wherever you find a
kafir into bracket he means hindu that
you kill them and if you open the Quran
surah tabba chapter number 9 verse
number five does say that wherever you
find a kafir kill them but he's quoting
a verse out of context.
If you read the context, the first few
verses of Surah Toba, chapter number n,
it speaks about a peace treaty between
the Muslims and the mushiks of Makkah.
And this peace treaty was unilaterally
broken by the mushiks of Makkah. By the
time Allah subhanana wa ta'ala reaches
verse number five,
he tells the mushiks, the enemies to put
things straight in four months time
otherwise the declaration of war. And in
the battlefield Allahh says that when
the kafids when the enemies come you
fight and you kill them. So this verse
is a verse which is revealed in the
battlefield that when the enemies come
to attack you don't get scared fight
them kill them. Now any army general to
boost up the morale of his soldiers he
will but naturally say that don't get
scared fight and kill the enemy. He not
say that don't kill the enemy don't
fight. So this verse is a verse which is
revealed in the battlefield and Aron
Shuri from verse number five he jumps to
verse number seven because surah tabba
chapter 9 verse number 6 has a reply to
his allegation verse number six says
that if the enemies seek asylum if they
seek peace don't just give it to them
escort them to a place of security
so that they will hear the word of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala the most merciful army
general today will tell his soldiers
that let the enemy But Allah says don't
just let them go, escort them to a place
of security.
And further if you analyze that all the
major religious scriptures,
all the major scriptures they talk about
fighting falsehood with truth.
All the major scriptures if you read the
Bible in the book of Exodus chapter
number 32, it speaks about fighting in
the Bible. In the book of numbers
chapter number 31 speaks about fighting.
In the gospel of Luke chapter number 22
Jesus Christ peace be upon says that
take the sword and fight. Same thing
with Mahabharat. It's a full epic
talking about fighting. Bhagat Gita is
the advice given by Shri Krishna to
Arjun to fight. Arjun says in Bhagat
Gita chapter number one verse number 43
to 46 that how can I kill my cousins? I
would prefer getting killed unarmed than
fighting my relatives. So Sri Krishna
says in Bhagat Gita chapter number two
verse number 23 he says how can such
impurities come in your mind they don't
want to fight how can you become so
important
chapter number two verse number 31 3 to
33 says that you are a shatria you
should fight only if you FIGHT WILL YOU
GET paradise
the moment I tell a Hindu a Bhagat Gita
he tells me no but this fight is truth
against falsehood so I said Same thing
Quran speaks truth against falsehood.
The moment I give the example of Bhagat
to Hindu you understand. Then he says
okay then Quran has got no problem.
So to a Christian you have to give the
example of the Bible to the Hindu you
have to give the example of his
religious scriptures come to common
terms
and if you analyze every country it has
it laws. Even India has it laws. In
India it is prohibited to rob. It's not
allowed by law.
It is probable to rape but yet people
are robbing yet people are raping. So
what do they have? They have a police
force. Police force to see to it that
they can punish the criminal. We have a
military if enemy comes to fight.
Every country has a military force has a
police force. So similarly what the
Quran talks in telling the Muslim that
when the enemies come you be prepared
and fight. So when every country in the
world has a police force has a military
force. So when Quran tells the Muslim
that in your state even you have a force
we should be ready to fight the enemies.
So what's the harm in the Quran?
We should realize that the Islamic
Sharia it's perfect
and if the Khalifa
gives an order the head of state to
fight and if he says all should take
part in fighting all should take part
irrespective whe engineer that is the
jihad striving you have no option that
law is not there in India and people
object
that in Islam
why does Islam take jaz attacks from the
non-Muslim and in the Islamic Sharia
there are even rights of the non-Muslim
we can give a talk on that and I write
articles every month in one of the Hajj
magazine Saudi Arabia of the rights of
non-Muslim Islamic Sharia I will not
permit to speak about this in detail but
there's allegation about Jazzy that how
come Islam
takes Jazia from the non-Muslim if you
know the background of Jazza why it is
taken you you will appreciate it. See,
jaza is the tax taken from the
non-Muslims who agree that they agree
with the rule of the Muslims, we agree
that you are the rulers and
the thing the ji has taken that in an
Islamic state if you are a Muslim and if
the khalifa tells that you should take
part in jihad or take part in the war
fighting of the falsehood it's
compulsory. You have no option
irrespective whether you're a doctor or
an engineer or a lawyer. When a
non-Muslim gives jya the Islamic state
gives him protection and the ja is how
much just a couple of hundred rupees
hardly and the Islamic state gives them
protection. If anyone attacks you we'll
protect you. You need not take part. If
someone gives me the option that should
I fight if the enemies come or would you
prefer paying 100 rupees and staying
peacefully at home and getting
protection I would prefer the second pay
a couple of hundred rupees and sit at
home relax I've got protection everyone
is protecting me
so actually this tax is just to
acknowledge that fine we accept that we
under protection and they get protection
and similarly if you analyze there are
various verses in the Quran which talks
about non-Muslim rights Allah says in
the Quran in surah mahina chapter number
16 verse number 8 that ask to those who
do not fight your faith and do not drive
you out of your home Allah advises you
to deal justly with them for Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala does not like those
who are unjust
but as to those kafir who fight your
faith verse number nine of surah mahana
chapter number 60 as to those kafir who
fight your faith and drive you out of
your home, Allah forbids you to go to
them for protection.
So if the non-Muslim is good, he doesn't
fight you
and doesn't drive you out of your home,
you have to deal with them justly. And
there are various rules and rights even
for the non-Muslims. This is the total
Islamic Sharia.
Irrespective if a Muslim, if he harms a
non-Muslim, even he gets punished.
If a Muslim robs from a non-Muslim's
house 1 kg of gold, his will be cut.
That is justice. If you analyze Islamic
Sharia is not barbaric, it is perfect.
And
the Sharia first lays down rules what
good things you should do. Not rob, not
rape, etc. But everyone will not follow.
So for them the punishment is laid down.
But the complete Sharia also includes
one of the pillars of Iman. The fifth
pillar of iman that is life after death.
Allah says in the Quran in surah mulk
chapter number 67 verse number two.
It's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of good deeds. This
life is a test for the hereafter and
life after death is compulsory for iman.
Without that iman is not complete. Why?
And there are many people who's alive
after death. It's illogical. Many people
don't believe in life after death. Many
people don't believe in almighty god.
How will you convince them logically?
The logical argument is I've given the
talk on Quran and modern science and
I've said there that the Quran contains
more than 6,000 verses out of which more
than a thousand verses speak about
science. Now if you analyze all the
verses that speak about science
approximately you can say 80% today
science tells us are 100% correct
because of advancement of science in all
these few hundred years. Today science
tells us that approximately 80% of
whatever Quran speaks about sign is 100%
correct. The remaining is 20% which is
ambiguous unknown. One amongst them is
life after death. Science hasn't reached
that far
to prove that there's life after death.
Science hasn't proved that there is ho
heaven. Science hasn't proved the
existence of jin. So there is 20% yet
science hasn't proved what the Quran
mentions.
So is it that I'm blindly believing life
after death? I say it's a logical
belief. My logic says that when 80% of
whatever the Quran has said is 100%
correct and 20% is ambiguous, neither
right neither wrong. My logic says that
inshallah even this 20% will be right.
It's a logical belief
and one of this 20% is life after death.
Now how to convince a person
in another way about
life after death? Suppose there's a
person who does not believe in life
after death and does not believe in
almighty God. How do you convince him? I
would like to ask you a question. Is
robbing good or bad?
Robbing is good or bad?
Bad. All say bad. Is raping good or bad?
Who says it is good?
No one. Out of 4,000 people, no one says
robbing is good. No one says raping is
good. All of you agree.
Yes. Okay, let's do an exercise.
Suppose
I am a smuggler. Hypothetically,
I'm a smuggler, a very powerful
smuggler.
I'm a robber. Number one in the world,
top robber.
And you are those people who don't
believe in life after death, don't
believe in God. Now if you are a person
who doesn't believe in God, doesn't
believe life after death and I am a
smuggler, a top smuggler, very
intelligent who believes in reason and
logic, I tell you that robbing is good.
I'm telling you robbing is good. I'm a
very logical person. I'm a very
scientific person. I am asking you all
of you so loudly said that robbing is
bad. Robbing is bad. I'm telling you
give me only one logical reason why
robbing is bad and I will stop robbing.
I am a very logical person. I am
intelligent person. I believe in
science. Only give me one logical reason
or scientific anything that why robbing
is bad and I will stop robbing. Can
anyone give me one logical reason?
You are taking other people's right. I
agree with the brother. I'm taking
somebody else's right. When I'm robbing
I'm robbing 1,000 rupees from him. I'm
taking his right. It is bad for him not
for me. I told you prove to me logically
why it is bad for me. If I take somebody
else's money, 1,000 rupees, I can go and
have dinner, I can go to a fivestar
hotel, I can see a movie, it's
benefiting me. I told you, give me one
logic in why it is bad for me. It is bad
for the person who's being robbed.
The brother said that I'll get punished
by the police. The police will catch me.
Brother, the police is in my pocket.
The ministers are in my pocket. I told
you I am a top smuggler, number one in
the world. If you're a small robber, if
you rob, you'll get caught.
I am a tough smuggler. You know the
mafia. The police is in their pocket.
The ministry is in the pocket. The
ministers, the judges are in the pocket.
They're on the payroll.
Give me one logical reason why it is
bad.
Huh?
You should remember starting of the
exercise I told you that you're those
people who do not believe in God. Do not
believe in here after I'm a smuggler.
You are trying to convince me that
robbing is bad. Give me one logical
reason only one.
Haram. Haram. Haram according to you. So
you don't rob.
It's not haram according to me.
If it is haram according to you, don't
rob. If it's prohibited, don't rob.
Who's telling you to rob? I'm telling
you prove to me I am a logical person.
Only one logical reason. Give me why it
is bad and I'll stop robbing. Only one,
not two. Only one logical with logic.
You will be robbed. Very good. Brother's
intelligent. Somebody will rob me.
Brother, I told you I'm number one
mafia. I've got 100 bodyguards. 100
bodyguards standing behind the stage.
All I've got AK-56 rifles.
If a small robber robs, somebody will
rob him. I'm number one in the world. I
have got bodyguards. No one can rob me.
No reason.
I will die with my
I die with my wealth. Even you have to
die. When I have to die. So what's the
problem? Everyone has to die. Will you
not die? So before I die enjoy life.
Even you will die. Even I will die. But
before I die, I will stay in a fivestar
hotel. I will have good food to eat. No
problem. Even you have to die when I
have to die.
consciousness will not allow me. Whether
my conscience is very good, I'm a
logical person. If your conscious says
don't drop, you don't rob. I am a
logical person. My conscience is very
clear. What I'm asking you that give me
a logical reason. If those people's
conscience is not to rob, you don't rob.
My conscience says it is good. When I
rob, I'm benefiting. I can enjoy life.
So why it is wrong? It's good.
Sorry.
What is better?
said because I haven't worked
I'm getting easy money.
Ah he's saying is easy money I'm not
working taking other piece of money
therefore I'm telling it is good easy
money rob why to work hard see if I tell
you how to get easy money it's good or
bad it is good so all these reasons are
telling me it is good what I'm telling
you give me one logical reason why it is
bad and I stop robbing you cannot give
me a single all of you said it is bad it
is bad can't give me a single what
happened to the people of Chennai
Sorry,
I can't hear you, brother.
America.
You will be next generation America.
He says I have to be Bush.
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Now all the chances are over.
Brother said if I'm robbing, I'll be
robbed. I told you I've got bodyguards.
Didn't I tell you?
I've got bodyguards. No one can rob me.
Okay, all your chances over now. Let's
turn the tables over.
[Music]
Your chance is over.
I don't mind having enemies.
No one can harm me. I have got
bodyguards. Now the exercise is over for
you. Now let's get to the answer. Now
let's get to the answer. As I told you
that this was exercise that if a person
comes to you and tells you that how come
you can prove about the Islamic Sharia.
This is the question you ask him. Now
let's turn the tables over. Turn the
tables over. You are that smuggler.
Hypothetically, hypothetically, you are
the smuggler. You are number one. And I
am a Muslim who's coming and approaching
you. And if you are the smuggler, you
tell me. That prove to me that robbing
is bad. If I tell you that the police
will catch you, you say police in my
pocket. If I say that you're harming
somebody else, you say it doesn't make a
difference to me. If you say it will
bite your conscience, you say that I
don't have a conscience at all. My
conscience is clean. If I tell you that
maybe someone will rob you, you say that
I've got bodyguards.
The first thing I'll do as a Muslim
after all the argument is prove to you
the existence of Allah subhana wa tala.
The reason a person who number one in
the world supposed to be the top mafia
and smuggler or robber
for him materialism becomes supreme. He
thinks he's the most powerful. The first
I'll do is I'll logically prove to him
the existence of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala which I've done in my talk is the
Quran God's word. So anyone who sees
this video cuz it is the Quran God's
word with an open mind he will agree
that the most supreme power is Allah
subhanana wa tala is almighty God. So
first I'll prove to him that he is not
the most powerful the most powerful
Allah subhana wa tala with the help of
the Quran and sands. Point number one
point number two after he agrees. Okay,
fine. I agree. God is the most powerful.
Then what type of God is this? Nothing
is happening to me. And he's right. We
have hundreds of example in the world.
What? Top smugglers, top robber, nothing
happens to them. Am I right or wrong?
Many people you get hundreds of robbers
and top people in the world who lead a
very luxurious life, nothing happens to
them. They die a peaceful death. Yes.
Some people get killed, some people get
arrested. But there are many who die.
they enjoy life and they die peace
fully.
So his question is if your God is so
great why doesn't he punish
what type of justice is there? Allah
says in the Quran in surah nisa chapter
number four verse number 14 Allah
subhananau wa ta'ala is never unjust in
the least degree he's never unjust in
the least degree and you ask any person
the moment he's not on the top when you
prove to him he's not on the top and if
there's injustice done to somebody else
he would not mind but no one would want
injustice to be done on them if someone
raped somebody else's wife or mother and
if someone is put to death you called
barbaric. Somebody rapes our mother,
then we think the death penalty is best.
So if it happens to us, he realizes that
there should be justice. Any human being
will agree that there has to be justice
done. But the question is how can
justice be done in this world? Everyone
can't get justice. For example, you may
be aware Hitler incinerated 6 million
Jews. How many? 6 million Jews. Suppose
you happen to catch Hitler today. Catch
Hitler today. What punishment can you
give him? What can you give him? Maximum
you can put him in the gas chamber. But
that will compensate for one. What about
the remaining 5 million
900,999?
What about them?
What about them? What type of a law is
this? Is it a just law? So Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Imran chapter number
three verse number 185 that
every soul shall have a taste of death
and the final recompense will be on the
day of judgment
and anyone who has been saved from the
hellfire and enters the garden he would
have achieved the objective of this
world for this life is nothing but mere
chattles of deception. So the final
hissab kitab final judgment is on the
day of judgment that is the isabita
final. So the only way you can prevent a
mafia who no one can touch here who
ministers are in his pocket judges are
in his pocket police in his pocket is by
punishment in the aar.
This only can complete the full sharia
belief in the akar. So the sharia has
three levels. Number one is
that it gives a law don't rob don't
rape. Number two if you rob or rape you
get punishment here. Number three
because those who don't want to follow
the law they can get caught they can
punished but every country doesn't have
the Sharia. America doesn't have the
Sharia India doesn't have the Sharia. So
they got caught free. So then they will
get the punishment in Akar. And if Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala has to give
punishment to Hitler and Akar, Allah
says in the Quran in surah Isa chapter
number four verse number 56 that as to
those who reject our signs, we shall
cast them into the hellfire and as often
as the skins are roasted, we shall give
them fresh skin so that they shall feel
the pain. So today science has realized
that the pain receptors and the skin. So
if Allah subhanana wa ta'ala wants to
burn Hitler 6 million times, he can do
it. He can even do it 12 million times.
It cannot be done in this world. So the
final judgment is in the you may get
part punishment here but the main isab
the main judgment is on the day of
judgment and Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
is malik
he's the master of the day of judgment.
But the final Sharia and the Islamic law
is only you can understand if you
believe in Akar. If you don't believe in
a there is no concept of robbing is bad,
no concept of raping is bad. All these
concept only come into picture if there
is life after death. So this is the
complete Sharia. And I would like to
conclude by giving the example that
whenever you want to judge the Sharia,
judge according to the authentic sources
that is the Quran and the Sunnah of the
prophet, the authentic had not on what
individual Muslims do or what the Muslim
society does.
Because what normally the media does,
they pick up black sheep of the
community. They pick up black sheep of
the community and they portray as though
they are the best that these are the
ideal Muslims, exemplary Muslim. And you
find in the media that if it comes in
the media, if a 50-year-old Muslim
marries a 16 year old girl, maybe an
Arab has come. So, it comes in
headlines. 50-year-old Arab Muslim
marries a 16-year-old girl. Headlines.
If a 50-year-old non-Muslim rapes a
six-year-old girl, it comes in news
briefs.
news briefs. So the media portrays I'm
aware that there are black sheep in a
community. There are black sheeps in our
community. There are people who call
themselves Muslim but they don't follow
the Sharia.
Islam says not to have alcohol, not to
have drugs. I know Muslims who can drink
the non-Muslim under the table. I'm
aware of it. These are black sheeps.
There are black sheep in every
community. The media picks them up and
portrays them as though they are
exemplary. And the example I gave
yesterday that if you want to judge a
car and if a person who does not know
how to drive the car sits behind the
steering wheel and he bangs up the car
who will you blame the driver or the
car? Driver. So don't judge Islam by
looking at the Muslims. Judge Islam by
the authentic source of the Quran. And
if you judge according to this you judge
by putting a driver behind the seat
who's an expert driver. So if you want
to observe a human being to know Islam
is the best example is the last and
final messenger prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Alhamdulillah.
Thank you very much brothers and
sisters.
[Music]
Oh.